[Music]
it's ps plus time again the extra set of
games each month added for extra and
premium members to enjoy 11 games this
time around which will be yours from
tuesday august 16th we've got a lot to
get through so let's crack on you've
likely heard the news that ps plus will
soon be the home of eight yakuza games
before the end of the year this time
around we have yakuza 0 yakuza kawami
and kawami 2. kiwami is in fact a remake
of the 2005 ps2 game so if you've ever
wanted to play the series from the
beginning you can with modern day polish
we play out the early days of kazuma
kiryu as he returns home after a stint
in prison this action rpg has us
returning to the yakuza underworld after
being blamed for a crime you didn't
commit and now it's time to find answers
kiwami 2 then continues that journey and
yakuza 0 offers a new perspective on all
this as it's a prequel set in the 1980s
from terrible karaoke singing to
collecting debts around the city the
yakuza games these action rpgs are
crammed full of content so much so that
it'll take around 100 hours to get a
platinum in any of these games a day to
try next we have tom clancy's ghost
recon wildlands an open world sandbox of
military possibilities a third-person
tactical shooter from back in 2017. we
arrive at this tropical country and we
are told to take out all the bad guys
controlling this place and then off we
go the game doesn't hold your hand do it
however you choose to alone or with a
team of three friends without a doubt
the best part of wildlands is playing
with your mates timing snipes from
unreal distances watching each other's
back in stealth missions and keeping
each other alive in frantic shootouts
playing with ai just doesn't have the
same feel each province in the wildlands
has a crime lord to find and then take
out which in turn gives us more
information about the boss of those
bosses the game has been updated many
times over the years so watch out if
you're ever walking through the jungle
because the predator lives there this is
no joke it's true at its core wildlands
is yet another rpg with skill points to
gain and unlock different tech which
admittedly does change your play style
so it is worth the grind tom clancy's
ghost recon wildlands is a blast with
the right people around you playing
alone it does get a little boring i have
to admit game 5 is dead by daylight an
asymmetric multiplayer survival game
that continues to receive constant
updates playing as four survivors we
must work together to escape completing
tasks along the way the thing is there's
a maniacal killer on your trail and
their job is to prevent anyone from
escaping at all dead by daylight was
released six years ago and continues to
be the best game in its genre thanks to
its constant updates right now you can
find survivors and killers from
different horror franchises michael
myers is here nancy and steve from
stranger things are here pyramid head
from silent hill is here the game is
packed with horror legends from
different mediums each with a different
level to master both as a hunter and the
prey definitely try dead by daylight if
you haven't already unless this kind of
game scares you of course game six is
bug snacks don't worry this isn't deja
vu it was on ps plus in the past we take
control of a journalist who is summoned
to snacktooth island which so happens to
be the home of bugs that are made out of
food our job is to find where everyone
vanished to and also to catch all those
creatures like edible pokemon with over
100 to find it should take a while as
each critter requires a different
technique to capture bug snacks was a
surprise hit in 2020 and since then the
review score has evened out at about 7
out of 10. game 7 is the greatest game
ever made uno a card game about matching
colors and numbers it's super simple to
learn but really difficult to win if
you're chatting with a group of friends
online this game is perfect for that
without all the hassle of playing with a
real deck of cards the only issue is
playing against ai that's not fun
because the ai never loses game 8 metro
exodus the third metro game based on the
novels of dmitry glykovsky an apocalypse
has devastated the world the thing is
it's all our fault humanity did this
thanks to nukes the game takes place
over a year as the survivors continue
their journey across russia with a harsh
winter rolling in the shooting mechanics
have been refined yet again and the
small dark corridors of the metro are
only one aspect this time around as more
open areas are here freely to explore
making the player decide which direction
is the safest and which will lead to a
fight with irradiated beings metro
exodus reviews at 7 out of 10. game 9 is
something from the 16-bit era trials of
mana has gone from the 2d world into
modern 3d standards this remake remains
an action role-playing game but the
super nintendo limits are no longer an
issue if you've ever played a jrpg like
early final fantasy games this is more
of that kind of goodness and you've
already decided before i even finish
this sentence if you're gonna try it or
not and finally games 10 and 11 are
monopoly madness and monopoly plus
madness takes the base game and
revolutionizes it into a frantic real
estate free-for-all this is all fine
until power-ups are thrown into the mix
drive a bulldozer into someone's hotel
cause a flood to people living near
water and block roads to prevent other
players from buying in your neighborhood
monopoly madness is nothing like the
board game it's crazy and it's actually
a pretty good time with friends monopoly
plus on the other hand is as close to
the base game as it could be the
difference is things move each character
interacts with the environment around
them giving monopoly a new lease of life
so that's august 2022 for ps plus on
extra and premium what are your thoughts
on this i'm adam you're awesome see ya